welcome to long now foundations seminar
about long term thinking I'm Kevin Kelly
along now
board member and author of what
technology wants the subject for this
evening is what cities want and to
present a kind of a full meal we have an
appetizer of our shorts or long shorts
which are a very short film to balance
the meaty meal you get immediately
afterwards so this short is by Japanese
student Yuri
Serizawa and was his senior thesis
project
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
good evening under Stuart branch from
the long now foundation remember when
senior projects are seen by one board
person it's a new world our speaker
tonight will not be signing his book if
mayor's ruled the world in the lobby
afterwards because it's not written yet
and so we actually this will be a
compare and contrast thing we've had a
lot of speakers they come here they sign
the book they talk about their book the
book was something usually that was you
know published maybe a year ago and
they're still trying to maintain some
residual interest in it because after
all they finished writing in 19 or so
months before that and it's all a little
bit of an act this is a real thing
this guy who's still actually figuring
it out he's about halfway through his
book you have question cards and if you
ask this sufficiently penetrating
question and may well wind up in this
wonderful book that we will get a taste
of tonight from Benjamin barber
[Applause]
if you'd like to buy the book you can
pay me in the back of the thing and I'll
send it to next next year I just flew
from New York this morning and I thought
I would bring a little East Coast
formality is there anyone else with the
tie and the audience here I don't think
so
someone good okay it did it on purpose I
thought you deserved a little East Coast
formality in San Francisco it's it's
wonderful to be here the long now
foundation lecture here at Fort Mason
and I want to thank Stewart Brand for
giving me the opportunity to talk about
a book that is in the making now and I
also want to thank Peter Schwartz who
introduced me to Stewart Brand and who
had a wonderful dinner a couple of
months ago in his house where we began
to talk about these things and Peter has
been an inspiration for me in thinking
about this book helped me make a trip to
Singapore in which I was able to think
about the ways in which Singapore
affects this so it's great that he's
here tonight thank you so much Peter
also an old friend is here tonight I
just want to mention Charlie helped her
and I want to mention because the
founder along with a couple of other
visionaries of demos the think tank
where I spent the last 6 years in New
York and have begun to think think about
this the book I'm working on is like all
my books everybody writes just one book
if they're an author and my book is
called democracy democracy in
Switzerland democracy that's strong
democracy and confrontation with jihad
and make world and now democracy in the
age of interdependence when we're
looking for democratic global governance
and don't know where to get it and
really I've been thinking a lot about
how in a world where all the challenges
we face are interdependent challenges
we can respond with constructive
interdependence and not with isolated
insular sovereign nation states that
refuse to cooperate with one another how
do we create new constructive
institutions that allow us to Glover and
govern globally and govern
democratically and I had a kind of
Epiphany because when I first was
writing I was just writing an outline in
which I was thinking about the various
institutions civil society NGOs citizen
movements States international
organization nation state organizations
and I had a chapter on cities but as I
looked at that chapter I realized that
if we shift our gaze and thinking about
global governance from nation-states to
cities there is a rapid and radical
shift in perspective where things
suddenly become possible that seemed
impossible and the book is now called if
mayors ruled the world why cities can
and should govern globally and how they
already do and tonight I'm going to talk
a little bit more about that part really
because the most important part of this
is I didn't have an idea wouldn't it be
great if cities govern globally won't it
be great if they cooperated across
borders what to be great if they
networked with one another instead I
realized the more I looked at it that
they already are networking they already
are governing across borders they are
already addressing the problems the
nation-states can't and won't so this is
a book about cities and when Stuart
brought me to Fort Mason the old Fort
Mason here with us where long now has
its headquarters and where this
wonderful theater is I it was wonderful
to come out here and look out over San
Francisco beg and and
it brought to mind the epigraph I'm
using for the book and I'm gonna read it
to you because it really fits perfectly
as we sit out here on the Fort Mason
pier it's from Walt Whitman's city of
ships and just a brief clip from its
city of ships city of the world for all
races are here all the lands of the
earth make contributions here city of
wharves and stores city of tall facades
of marble and iron proud and passionate
City meddlesome mad extravagant city
spring up o city that's Walt Whitman one
hundred and what thirty years ago
looking at a port city New York and
thinking about the way in which cities
embody the world of which they are a
part in the way that states don't and so
that's the perfect starting place for an
examination of the role that cities
might play and let me do some
introducing of what the themes are here
first and then in our discussion with
Stewart and with all of you I think we
can cover some of the ground that I hope
to cover in the book but let's start at
the beginning in a teeming world of too
much difference and too little
solidarity with democracy and deep
crisis everywhere with sovereign states
unable unwilling to cooperate across
borders politicians citizens scholars
alike have begun to talk and think about
cities if you love cities you're gonna
love the 21st century says Bruce Katz
the city has in fact become our
indisputable human habitat urbanity may
or may not be our nature but for better
or worse by chance by design it defines
how we live
more than half the world's people now
live in cities that just happened last
year the UN announced cities are where
civilization is forged where creativity
is Unleashed community solidified and
citizenship realized if we are to be
rescued from global anarchy the city may
turn out to be the agent of our
salvation that at least is the argument
I want to try to make the foremost
challenge we face today is to establish
institutions capable of addressing the
multiplying cross-border problems of an
interdependent world without
surrendering democracy to save ourselves
from both anarchic and monopolistic
forms of globalization and to do that we
need global democratic bodies that
actually work nation-states have made
little progress towards this kind of
global governance to Incline by their
nature to rival reaching mutual
exclusion they seem went essentially
indisposed to cooperation and incapable
of establishing global common goods
moreover and this is a challenge for us
democracy is locked in the tight embrace
of nation-states and there seems little
chance either for democratizing
globalization or for globalizing
democracy as long as the flourishing of
democracy depends on the survival and
flourishing of warring nation states so
what then can we do the path forward
lies before us obvious but unchartered
why not let City is the most networked
and interconnected of our political
associations defined above all by
collaboration and pragmatism by
creativity and multi-culture let's
cities do what states cannot if as
Edward Glaeser has written in his new
book
about cities the strength that comes
from human collaboration is the central
truth behind civilizations success and
the primary reason why cities exist both
Glaser's right then surely cities can
and should govern globally in a phrase
let mayor's rule the world
now networked cities already encircle
the globe and webs of culture commerce
communication and they can reasonably be
expected to do formally what they are
already doing informally govern through
voluntary cooperation and shared
consensus if mayors ruled the world the
three and a half billion people over
half the world's population who are
urban dwellers and the many more in X
urban neighborhoods beyond could
participate locally and cooperate
globally at the same time a miracle of
civic glow Cala T that promises
pragmatism before politics innovation
instead of ideology practical solutions
in place of sovereignties posturing the
challenge of democracy in the modern
world has been how to join participation
which is local with power which is
central cosmopolitanism responds by
imagining citizens rooted in urban
neighborhoods where participation and
community are still possible reaching
across frontiers to confront and contain
centralized power it imagines them
joining one another to oversee and
regulate anarchic globalization and the
illegitimate market forces it unleashes
about 85 years ago John Dewey embarked
on what he called a search for the great
community a community they might tie
people together through common
activities powerful symbols into what he
called an expansive public organized
around communication in doing so Dewey d
linked democracy from mere
formal government from the state and he
insisted that it be understood as a deep
form of association embracing the family
the school industry and religion Dewey
was certain if it embraced as a life of
free and enriching communion then
democracy would come into its own but
only and this is a quote from Dewey only
when free social inquiry is
indiscernibly wedded to the art of full
and moving communication Dewey was in
describing the great community in effect
describing the essence of the great
modern city just being born when he
wrote a world governed by cities gives
democratic form to do his aspirational
vision of a great community it does not
require that a new global governing
edifice be artificially constructed from
the ground up and it doesn't mean that
networked cities must be endorsed by the
nation states that they will partially
supersede it places the emphasis on
bottom-up citizenship civil society and
on voluntary community across borders
rather than top-down prescriptions an
executive man and mandates emanating
from unitary global rulers which is what
most people think about when you talk
about global governance New York's Mayor
Bloomberg may seem hubristic yet his
rhetoric hardly Dewey's but rooted and
realism resonates with the power of
municipal localism played out in an
interdependent world here's what he said
at MIT just a month or two ago he said
quote I have my own army in the NYPD my
own state department much too foggy
bottom's annoyance but then New York he
said has every kind of people from every
part of the world and every kind of
problem and if Washington doesn't like
it well Bloomberg allows I don't listen
to Washington very much
it is not boasting but both the burdens
and the possibilities of the city that
give Mayor Bloomberg's claims residents
Frazee insists quote and this is again
Bloomberg the difference between my
level of government and other levels of
government is that action takes place at
the city level close quote
while American government right now is
quote just unable to do anything the
mayors of this country still have to
deal with the real world
close quote I think what Bloomberg is
saying is that while presidents
pontificate principled mayor's pick up
the garbage this kind of can-do thinking
is echoed by organizations like the
ICLEI the local governments for
sustainability whose report following
the no-can-do UN climate summit in
Durban at the end of 2011 observed quote
that local government is where the
rubber hits the road when it comes to
responding to the human impacts of
climate change
close quote the city's approach to
climate change in fact emerged much
earlier first with the US Conference of
Mayors climate protection agreement back
in 2000 2005 after the Kyoto Protocol
had been signed and then last year again
after Mexico City where little progress
was made by the states 207 cities at the
world mayor's summit on climate in
Mexico City sign that the documents that
the states did not pledging themselves
to honor quote strategies and actions
aimed at reducing greenhouse gas
emissions this is no small thing nearly
85% of global emissions of carbon come
from cities
so if city mayors around the world take
action themselves cooperatively a great
deal can be done even if the United
States and China and India and Canada
refuse to take the next
as nation states by expanding and
diversifying the networks through which
they are already cooperating cities are
then proving they can do things together
that states can't and won't I proposed
will propose at the end of the book a
parliament of cities but the idea really
isn't so bold what would a Parliament's
of cities be but the formalization of
voluntary global networks already in
existence a global Parliament's of
mayors would not have to enact laws or
give orders it could simply be the place
where consensus was reached by mayors
and cities interested in taking action
voluntarily the World Congress of the
meta network that's already there called
the United cities and local governments
in fact met in 2010 with a congress with
3,000 delegates from over a hundred
countries and one might say that that
meeting in two years ago
was the first meeting of a informal
global Parliament of cities and what is
a prospective global civil religion but
the common Civic expression of how
people actually live in cities and what
enables migrant workers whether they're
taxi drivers or corporate accountants or
rock guitarists to roam from city to
city looking for work without ever
really leaving town I thought of that
when I was in London two years ago and a
Sikh driver who was driving in London I
said how do you like driving in London
he said well it's better than driving in
Shanghai where I was but it's not as
good as New York where my brother is and
where I'm going next year to drive a cab
he was moving around the world from city
to city in the transportation industry
without really giving a thought to the
differences between cities cities
obviously common varieties of every kind
and there's been a lot of discussion
recently about how different they can be
from one another but they do none
the less resemble each other
functionally and architectural II how
many ways are there stuff a million
people into a radically delimited space
even in the 18th century jean-jacques
rousseau observed that all capital
cities are just alike Paris and London
seemed to me to be the same town and
those of us who travel no and I written
about this in McWhirter with the
pervasive commercial culture that is
everywhere in the world indeed capital
cities everywhere feel very much the
same the cross-border civil society then
that I want to envision as the future of
global cooperation is simply a global
network of the partnerships and
associations that already exists and
share social values of the communities
organized around the struggle for
universal human rights that already
exist of the religious associations with
an echo medical out look like focal re
the progressive Catholic institution
with interfaith basis in over 80
countries of the international societies
of artists of the social networks of
friends by rolling out to encompass
strangers this kind of network is not
waiting to be born it's born and already
half grown waiting rather to be
recognised exploited and formalized all
of the synapses that link urban gnomes
nodes are already marking new pathways
to interdependence novel mechanisms of
cooperation common decision-making are
already allowing cities to address in
common issues of security trade climate
trains weapons proliferation cultural
exchange drugs transportation public
health immigration and technology I tell
a story in the book about Ray Kelly the
new police chief after 9/11 of New York
City who initially under Mayor Giuliani
sent
twelve of the best cops to in his
intelligence division to Washington to
join Homeland Security and after 18
months they came home and said we're
doing nothing FBI doesn't talk to the
CIA CIA doesn't talk to Interpol
nobody's talking to each other we're
learning nothing in Washington and Ray
Kelly said okay you go to Singapore you
go to Hong Kong you go to Paris you go
to Frankfurt you go to Rio he Reedus
patched them to 12 cities and one reason
New York has rain remained safe until
now is that it has one of the best
intelligence cooperation networks in the
world working not through Interpol
not through Washington not through
Homeland Security but city to city to
city so there is a real possibility in
the informal kinds of Association that
already exists of a world in which
genuine cooperation is possible it
doesn't have to be formal and as a
political scientist like the one who had
to I'm not really saying to you don't
make it formal I'm saying to myself as a
political scientist we always look for
formal institutions but Ray colonna's
Chicago alderman said recently after the
introduction of a bike share program by
Mayor Rahm Emanuel he said I first saw
how well bike share innovations work on
a trip to Seville in Spain so he came
back to Chicago and he worked with Rahm
Emanuel and
Emanuel subsequently promised a hundred
miles of green protected bike lanes on
major Chicago thoroughfares is currently
making good on that promise
sharing green ideas among cities and
cooperating on slowing climate change in
city networks like the c40 but is of
course not the same thing as ruling the
world but it does suggest that cities
are far ahead of states and confronting
the daunting challenges of
interdependence through voluntary and
informal cooperation they are doing a
lot more than nation-states ever have I
was listening to public radio when I was
in San Francisco a couple of months ago
and I heard an extended program on
climate change mitigation efforts
looking forward to flooding in the San
Francisco Bay Area as a result of ocean
rise and the way in which officials in
the city are already anticipating and
trying to deal with mitigation efforts
in a way that Washington is not an a
Republican Congress and maybe even a
Democratic Congress never will
network cities are already supplementing
the brave but endangered experiment of
the European community in pooling
sovereignty and in time might supplant
the corporate and money tainted
machinations of the g9 or the g20 with
the parliaments of cities that will need
ask no states permission to assemble to
seek consensual solutions to common
problems and to voluntarily comply with
common policies of their own choosing
when mayor's like Michael Bloomberg of
New York Institute measures to end
smoking or control childhood obesity by
curbing 16 outs and bigger soda sales as
he did last week Washington can only
look on in wonder deprecating or
admiring the initiatives but impotence
in the face of mayors elsewhere in the
world who might choose to do the same
there are more non-smoking cities around
the world now not just non-smoking
restaurants bars hotels and places of
business but non-smoking cities then one
possibly could have imagined just 10 or
15 years ago
neither soda nor tobacco companies
omnipotent with national governments
through their bullying lobbies and
seductive bank accounts can do very much
at the local level other than whine and
sulk the call to let mayors and those
who represent they and those they
represent become global governors and
enable their residents to reach
cross frontiers and become citizens
Without Borders does not then reflect
utopian aspiration or the longing for an
impossible regime of global justice it
demands only that we recognize a world
already in the making one coming into
being without systemic planning or the
blessing of any state-based Authority
that we take advantage of the unique
urban potential for cooperation
unhindered by those obdurate forces of
sovereignty nationality and ideology
that have historically hobbled an
isolated nation states inside fortresses
labeled independence and autonomy now
let's not be naive it's true if mayors
are to rule the world it's clear they'll
have to pay dues to prime ministers and
presidents cities may already constitute
networks of collaboration that influence
the global economy and bypass the rules
and regulations of states and they may
as Saskia Sassen has written have more
in common with one another than the
regional centers in their own
nation-states and they may as sawsan
said cities global cities may no longer
be quote deeply articulated with the
hinterland speaking of the nation-states
but that being true still cities lie
within the jurisdiction and the
sovereignty of the sovereign hinterland
bodies they sometimes manage to bypass
or transcend Mayor Bloomberg may have
his own army but let him try to deploy
it in Cuba or Washington or Albany or
even across the river in Hoboken or in
Yonkers a few miles up from Manhattan he
can cut potential bike routes through
Manhattan but try doing it on the New
York Thruway or the interstate highway
system governance is about power as well
as problems jurisdiction as well as
function so the relationship of cities
to States has to be of critical concern
and there are two crucial questions are
the interests of cities and of this
states to which cities belong in harmony
or in conflict and can cities do what
they do in the face of national
governments that are not merely
indifferent but hostile to their global
aspirations just ask Washington DC the
city what the courts did about
Washington DC's effort to ban handguns
there and you'll have an example of how
cities don't always have their way the
answer is in fact both these questions
is complex and one of the things I want
to do in the book is try to deal in some
detail probably boringly but necessarily
with issues of legal and political
jurisdiction but what's clear from the
outset is that the interests of cities
and of the nations to which they belong
and belong as the right word are often
necessarily in tension and that however
networked and interdependent cities may
become in terms of their economic
technocratic and cultural functions they
live under the law and in the shadow of
the legal jurisdiction an executive
force of what are still very powerful
states and again following Saskia Sassen
quote what contributes to growth in the
network of global cities may well not
contribute to growth in nations China
has found that with Shanghai and Hong
Kong and now at Chongqing and other fast
growing cities that the interests of the
National elites and the interests of
those cities are in fact antagonistic if
the growth of global cities is
correlated with deficits for national
governments then governments are surely
unlikely to sit back and do nothing
while their power and their suzerainty
is eroded they'll fight back they'll try
to bring global cities back under their
control demonstrating forcefully that
however collaborative and trans
territorial cities may regard themselves
they remain the creatures of state power
now unlike corporations or Association
the states are by definition territorial
while cities are not in this sense
territorial not locked in a Ciro a
zero-sum game where the frontier of one
nation ends another nation begins that
makes the relationships of Nations with
regard to the frontier zero-sum but
cities are apart from one another
separated by wide spaces and their
relationships are based on communication
trade transportation culture they are
relational and they do not exist in a
zero-sum game with one another and
that's a fundamental difference but
still cities do sit on a state's
territory and as a consequence are
pulled in drawn into the game the
zero-sum game of frontiers while
citizens can dream across borders they
are defined by and they owe their
loyalty neither to the local city alone
nor to some emerging global Cosmopolis
but to their national flags patriotic
anthems and defining national missions
for Mayor Bloomberg and his proud New
Yorkers and you can count me among them
this means that we must harken not just
in New York New York is a wonderful town
and look at the Statue of Liberty as a
tourist attraction but have to harken
also to America the Beautiful and to
that larger nation that claims to be a
beacon of Liberty for which the Statue
of Liberty stands in France it reminds
intellectuals in the fifth
Hamdi small that la misión seven at
least the civilizing mission of the
French is in fact French and not
Parisian in Germany it warns that
Deutschland uber alles is not just a
signifier of vanished Imperial Hotel but
also of the sovereignty of Germany over
Frankfurt and Berlin Texas may sometimes
imagine itself severing the ties that
bind it to the United States and Austin
might imagine itself an independent
liberal oasis
in the Texas desert but neither Dallas
nor Austin are about to declare they're
interdependent that their independence
from Texas or the United States the
interdependence of cities may erode
their ties to nation states and draw
them towards collaboration with one
another but no state worth its salt as
measured by its sovereignty will stand
still and watch cities annul
subsidiarity and escape the
gravitational pull of their sovereign
mother ships this is true even in
Singapore city-state were paradoxically
a city must coexist with the territorial
coterminous state that exercises
sovereignty over itself as a city and
the state nor is this all negative this
is putting it because I'm looking at it
from the perspective of cities that's
putting it perhaps in a negative light
but obviously cities nation states are
more than just archaic burdens for
cities to bear national communities are
important markers of identity they
helped establish the greater communities
rooted in common history common language
a common narrative that allows urban
residents to share citizenship beyond
town limits to suggest the tension
between urban identity and national
identity is not necessarily the favored
one or the other it's just a state a
fact with which global cooperation among
cities has to come to terms the success
of cities in other words must find a way
to supplement the efforts of states and
offset sovereign in capacities without
pretending nations away they're not
going away or making them villains in
the story of democratic globalization
they're not villains the argument I'm
offering then also requires that we look
at and build upon the successes of
lesser-known but robust civic entities
and networks like the International
Union of local authorities like
metropolis the world association of the
major metropolis is
like the American League of Cities like
the ICLEI which is the local governments
for sustainability to see 40 cities that
are dressed on climate change that Bill
Clinton helped establish the united
cities and local governments the new
hanseatic league that a thousand years
after the earlier Hanseatic League has
organized cities from nine nations
around the North Sea to cooperate and
become more democratic they include
parts of the old Soviet Union as well
the European Union Secretariat of Cities
the u.s. mayors climate protection
agreement the Association of us mayors
against illegal government guns the mega
city foundations and on and on and on I
will provide in the book a chart of over
200 such global networks with anywhere
from 30 to 200 or 3 or 400 in some cases
thousand member city members that
participate and cooperate in a wide
variety of areas from security and
weapons proliferation to climate change
transportation and health these clumsily
names and seemingly dull bureaucratic
constructions are in fact birthing an
exciting new Cosmopolis whose activities
and ambitions hold the secret to
fashioning the global processes
the institutions that states have failed
to create such networks more than a few
created by or contributed to by New York
City's hyperactive mayor help explain
mr. Bloomberg's colorful urban hyperbole
with or without authoritative
underwriting Network cities and mega
cities are likely to determine whether
democracy whether even civilization
itself survives in the coming decades
when the primary challenge will remain
how to overcome the violent conflict
within and between states and how to
address the cataclysmic economic and
ecological anarchy and the inequalities
and
Justices the absence of democratic
global governance will occasion
we're already stumbling into that
seductive but deadly anarchy in which
pandemics and ecological catastrophes
are allowed to flourish in sovereignties
name not at the expense of my
sovereignty are you going to monitor my
air quality or inspect my weapons
production or regulate my fracking
methods or pass a law of the Seas which
the United States has still not signed
we're already living in an era of global
private monopolies and money and
influence that are empowered under the
banner of Liberty but are anything but
free what is missing is obviously not
globalization but globalization that is
public rather than private democratic
rather than hegemonic a Galit aryan
rather than monopolistic in struggling
against this global anarchy and the
brute force winner-take-all mentality
that facilitates cities working across
borders make a difference by working
voluntarily and cooperatively workin
bottom-up to pursue sustainability
justice democratic equality they can
mitigate the depredation the
depredations of our fractious states
they can temper they can even regulate
the global market states that states
have been unwilling or unable to control
cities that are woven into an informal
Cosmopolis can become as the Paulus once
was new incubators of democracy this
time on a global scale the tendencies of
cities have generally remained anti
ideological and in this practical sense
both pragmatic and democratic from the
beginning under siege from puerile
Marauders in an earlier millennium
cities nevertheless had to persist in
overseeing the necessities of everyday
life cities are after all habitats for
common life there were people live and
hence where they learn they
they work they sleep they pray they play
they grow and eat and finally they die
even with armies at the gates or plagues
in the streets city dwellers have had to
occupy themselves with a diurnal as well
as sometimes with the sublime their
paramount aims and thus the aims of the
mayors they elect to serve them are
mundane collecting garbage and
collecting art rather than collecting
votes or collecting allies putting up
buildings and running buses rather than
putting up flags and running political
parties securing the flow of water
rather than the flow of arms fostering
education and culture in place of
national defense and patriotism
promoting collaboration not
exceptionalism suckering knowing
participation and pride rather than
institutionalizing blind patriotism
cities have little choice to survive and
flourish they must remain hospitable to
pragmatism to problem-solving to
networking to cooperation come hell or
high water war or siege they have to
worry about plowing the streets and
providing parking and yes always and
everywhere picking up the garbage
they're defining association with trade
with business transportation
communication digital technology and
culture generically with creativity and
imagination is a natural feature of
human proximity and population density
as Richard Florida has written quote the
real key to unleashing our creativity
lies in humanity's greatest invention
the city cities are veritable magnetrons
for creativity he writes creativity and
imagination we know Drive invention they
drive commerce they drive culture but
they are also engineers of democracy now
keep in mind the surging history of
urbanization and industrialization we've
been talking about in post
industrialization is
just really a hundred years or so old
even a half century ago in 58 1958
Edward Banfield the great sociologist of
that time wrote with confidence quote
most of the people of the world live and
die without ever achieving membership in
a community larger than the family or a
tribe and outside of Europe and America
the concerting of behavior in political
associations and corporate organizations
is a rare and recent thing that's just
fifty years ago he wrote that in the
half-century since we've watched cities
morphing into mega cities of tens of
millions intersecting with other cities
to comprise today's burgeoning
megalopolis and mega regions in which a
rising portion of the Earth's population
now dwelve
when Banfield published his book the
moral basis of a backwards society there
were over 300 Indian cities that were
still villages that are today cities of
over a million China today has six
hundred new cities over a million people
that 50 years ago when Banfield was
writing did not exist as anything but
towns and sometimes not even as that
it's true that tribes still dominate
certain cultures but even in Africa mega
city conurbations have emerged that
represents territorially immense urban
juggernauts that encompass populations
of twenty million or more typical for
examples africa's lagos ibadan continent
where lagos alone is projected to reach
25 million people by 2025 making it the
world's third largest city after Mumbai
and Tokyo in a Nigeria that now has six
cities over a million and another dozen
with 500,000 to a million all of them
growing rapidly
then there's Kinshasa Brazzaville across
the Congo River from one another
interconnected city
in two different states other megacities
have appeared in the in de gand antic
plane in China's pearl Delta the
Northeast Carter of the United States
Japan's Tahiry Oh Belt Europe's
so-called golden bananas some belt along
the western Mediterranean and the
greater são Paulo Metroplex in Brazil
and of course China's cities I've
already said are growing so fast it's
nearly impossible to keep up Mackenzie
did a study last year that suggested of
the top 600 cities with respect to GDP
136 of those 600 over the next 10 years
will be newly added and they will all be
Chinese the concentration of urban
populations into ever more complex
systems at once both denser and more
expansive continues to accelerate
blurring the distinctions between urban
and suburban between town and country
nor is the compass of these
conglomerations exclusively territorial
far from it again in her study of New
York London and Tokyo Saskia Sassen
argues that as they become service
centers for the new global economy quote
in many regards these three cities
function as one trans territorial
marketplace not a bad term for many of
the world's mega cities trans
territorial marketplaces she goes on
they serve not just one by one but they
function as a triad representing a new
form of tropi less that is neither
territorial nor virtual but a network
comprised by the intersecting and
overlapping global city functions they
serve close quote and it gets even
weirder there are these new hybrids new
corporate instant cities like new Sandow
city in South Korea planned to open up
in 2015 to start with a population of
250,000 people and then there's the
opposite the unplanned refugee camps in
quote cities like Dada band Kenya which
has up to 300
people refugees jammed into an urban
infrastructure that served by mobile
courts traveling council services from
the UN and other agencies and sometimes
youth education centers and as the
notion of the urban develops in the new
millennium people talk about new imagine
see worlds to be set adrift in the ocean
one of which has already been legally
founded as see stead and is to be
launched within the decade in the
Pacific Ocean off California and then
some have proposed sky world's this
isn't science fiction this isn't
Hollywood untethered from the land
conceived as future sanctuaries urban
colonies for people for whom the planets
continents have grown too small that
such daydreams are more than just
fantasy as evident from the plans of
futurist entrepreneurs like Richard
Branson who hope to service such
colonies with novel companies like his
Virgin Galactic which is reportedly
preparing now to offer space mile
benefits to its customers even old line
politicians like Newt Gingrich have been
talking about colonizing the moon as
staples of their campaign patter for
some time idealists and dreamers have
looked even further here in the West
Coast I think you know that well beyond
our known urban bama myths and linked
mega cities there are dreamers who are
in search of McLuhan's Global Village a
moat in his prescient eye 60 years ago
but today an abstraction being given
form not only in digital and virtual
forms like the cloud but in global
economic markets and the complex urban
networks that accompany them the urban
philosopher Konstantinos deoxidize
pursuing his own science of human
development he calls acoustics has
predicted the emergence of a single
planetary city eka Menon pause he gives
us sociological and futurist spin to
science fiction writers like Isaac
Asimov and William Gibson who for
decades have been a
imagining global urban agglomerations at
a planetary scale and just beyond the
global village pushing out from the
imagined ekam a nopales one can catch a
glimpse of gaya that mythic organic
entity that in the hypothesis positive
by James Lovelock is an involving and
self-regulating system in which
biosphere atmosphere hydrosphere impetus
fear all work together on behalf of a
sustainable and integral planet the
whether it's urban or not remains a
puzzle in gaya Club lockup at the sizes
we may find ourselves and all other
living beings to be parts and partners
of a vast being who and her entirety has
the power to maintain our planet as a
fit habitat for life well clearly we've
moved well beyond the world of fracking
and the XL pipeline in these visions but
there's a reality to it the US
government has actually put up grants
for people thinking about interplanetary
and interstellar tribal visions of the
future actually being funded by the US
government the journey then from Polish
to megalopolis from parochial pieces to
imagined whole has been a journey all
along from the simple to the complex the
rural to the urban the local to the
global the mundane to the imaginative
and the fantastic the development has a
had a feel of in electability about it
with populations ever more concentrated
Commerce more global complexity
continually augmented inevitable or not
and whether we like it or not many don't
like it the development has witnessed
the forging of civic cultural and
commercial networks that have made human
association in the form of urbanity
the touch-tone for a sustainable human
civilization what this then suggests to
me is a world in which cities
already are playing a role in global
governance and a role that if it is
expanded can increasingly solve problems
that states cannot solve states will not
govern globally that is clear cities can
and are not by writing a global charter
or cities like the charter of the United
Nations
not by promulgating a new Declaration of
Human Rights we've got that we
understand rights what we lack is the
global democratic mechanisms by which
they can be enacted and enforced without
civic foundations to give mechanisms of
enforcement wait rights are as Madison
once said of the Bill of Rights of the
United States Constitution parchment
barriers offering little protection
against abuse what we require are ways
to act informally and piecemeal across
borders that give substance and
sustenance to declarations of human
rights to take a poignant example if
terrorists managed to detonate a nuclear
vise device it may be the Great Satan
United States that they aim at but it
will be cities like San Francisco and
New York that will suffer the carnage
cities cannot wait for states to figure
out the meaning of interdependence as
David Wiley has observed quote to
redress the disconnect cities and towns
will themselves have to begin to elect
representatives to make common cause
with other threatens urban populations
that then is the challenge we come
full-circle can cities save the world
that may be too daunting a challenge but
it seems possible that they can rescue
democracy from sovereignty and find ways
to help us govern our world
democratically and bottom-up if only
informally it won't be easy but I do
believe not only that it is do
but as I speak this evening it is being
done thank you
Thanks let's go sit this is a good sign
they spat a lot of questions I've got
one starting in which is Mayor Bloomberg
is mayor of New York as much as he wants
but he's not mayor of the New York
metropolitan area
never mind of the mega pollen area that
reaches from Boston to Raleigh how does
that play out one of the most difficult
questions we face in thinking about
whether cities can actually govern is
where their territorial boundaries are
so cities have boundaries they have they
do have boundaries they don't but they
do not have boundaries that are
contiguous with the boundaries of other
cities and that's the good news the bad
news is it's uncertain where their
boundaries are partly because boundaries
are tenuous it's hard to tell so the
tri-state region of Newark New York and
Westchester and Connecticut southern
Connecticut are clearly in a single
metropolitan region but the mayor is not
the mayor in Brussels there are 12
mayor's there 12 districts there's no
mayor of Brussels there 12 mayors of 12
districts so so it's just a nightmare
it's the solution it's a nightmarish
solution but it's much less a nightmare
because what you're talking about here
is technical political and
administrative questions not the lack of
will and the lack of capacity to govern
across borders and with nation states
which have the perfect setups we know
every country has a head whether it's a
tyrant a king prime minister or a
president they can gather together but
never will mayors will gather with much
less authority with much less sense of
who exactly it is they represent but
they can and will gather and they are
acting together without those questions
being clarified in the strength I think
of the system that I'm thinking about
and it's already happening is that
because it's informal because it's
voluntary because it doesn't require
jurisdictional capacity it means that an
awful lot can be done in the face of
uncertainty over that kind of a question
question from Steven Johnson he says 340
years ago many thought cities were on a
path eternal decay and decline Manhattan
was no pit everybody expected to
basically die now cities our path to
salvation what were the main forces that
drove that change well in my second hour
I'm going to that question because that
of course is a story about the history
of cities but the simple answer is
cities are shaped by economics and the
economics of agriculture and trade
fostered and shaped the early medieval
and early modern city the politics and
economics of capitalism shaped the 18th
and century a 19th century industrial
city the automobile shaped the 20th
Century City and Technology the
information and service economies are
shaping the 21st seas and what we're
seeing is not some what has changed it
Stephen Johnson is well in part but
whatever what I want to say is that this
the question I think referred to and
what's happening is that some say the
Rust Belt cities are in bad shape but
new information centers cities are in
very good shape and they emerge just as
old trading cities didn't do very well
when new industrial cities were
manufacturing was undertaken started
working so we're seeing the passing of
the baton from one set of cities to
another not the eclipse of the city
there's a hypnotist that I think partly
Stephen Johnson is referring to you that
you know the city's environmentalists
might crowd look down our noses from a
great height at cities and thought
everybody should go to the countryside
and we went out started communes to
prove that that was the better way to go
and you know that didn't work out so
well it says this you know this may be
just fashion we're talking about and you
and I are writing a nice little wave of
fashion and in 10 years time everybody
remember when we thought cities were the
solution
well those folks are gonna have to do
something about demographics because 50
or 75 years ago about a third of the
world's population lived in cities only
about half of developed countries lived
in cities today 75 to 80 percent of
people in developed world live in cities
and a half of the people in the less
developed the developing world do so
people cities are growing we will like
it or not I said in talking this evening
a lot of people don't necessarily like
what this is and I have a chapter about
you know the idle of the fantasy of the
countryside of nature of the wild parks
and so on that's there but the city is
our destiny we will live there we may
not like it
cities will differ from one and another
but the majority of the world's
population will live there by 2050 it's
estimated that 85 percent of the world's
population and 95 percent of the Western
population will be living in cities over
50,000 now again 50,000 is very
different than 5 million which is very
different than 20 million so to say well
50,000 isn't really City but it's it's
more of a city than the towns of the
18th and 19th century short world so
here's a question from Jonathan Poole do
you advocate disenfranchising the
billions of those who dwell in villages
and small towns and just just burst
farms and the horrible rural despite the
fed state population despite the fact
that would take out the tea party I do
not recommend that no they're one of the
most difficult issues that again I'm
looking at the book is the issue of
representation how can cities represents
a world in which right now half of the
world's population isn't in cities and
even let's say in 50 years only 15 or 20
percent aren't in cities what about them
so that is a fundamental question but
again the difference is that within
formal governance cities are not
claiming to govern on behalf of others
Bloomberg is not saying that people in
rural high schools can't buy 16 ounce or
20 ounce
so does they just can't do it in New
York and what we're talking about here
is cooperative cities huge black market
developing in Jersey I'm sure you're I'm
sure you're right but you see what I'm
what I'm saying again is that when
you're looking at informal and voluntary
governs there's no reason why towns and
villages and people living in rural
areas can't say oh we like that we want
to do that - no one's making them do it
no one's making cities do it no one's
making them do it so when you're looking
at bottom-up forms of organization it's
very different than we're looking at
top-down mandated executive Fiats which
order everybody in a region to do the
same thing Kevin Kelly asked question if
the benefits of cities continue to grow
in the future shouldn't we expect more
breakaway city states like Singapore
would they have any right to secede they
have every right and absolutely no
capacity or power to do so so no army or
what because they yeah I mean how do you
do it the new york police force isn't
going to take on the US marines Norman
Mailer suggested that Manhattan actually
back in 1974 become a country of its own
and actually a lot of Americans think
that's a good idea too I think but oh
yes Green that's not gonna happen but
we're relating with them to what we're
looking at is more integration not more
disintegration we're not looking at
things pulled apart we're looking at
cities working together and the degree
to which they are part of or autonomous
within States is less important than
what they are doing together and we're
sort of focusing right now in these
questions on the cities themselves
whereas the focus of my thinking is on
what cities can do together and how they
work together it raises all these
important questions about borders and
the greater regions and representation
those questions have to be dealt with
but what's interesting is that cities
are all ready doing this and that's the
thing that I've you know have found so
impressive I started out saying I wish
they would do this and then I found that
they are so maybe you could say cities
already are city states to a certain
extent and
and we've seen it historically the
cities we remember and care about Athens
after all sort of invented democracy and
Venice was a city-state basically for
800 years of a very turbulent European
history
Singapore is a phenomenal event I'm
curious when you you went to Singapore
recently they listen carefully to you
I'm sure what did you discover when you
were there that both spoke to your
thesis and challenged it well the most
interesting and I'll come to that in a
minute because it's a sideline but very
important what what in terms of my
thesis what I found is that even within
Singapore the tensions between the city
and the state even though the
coterminous are very real what Singapore
does as a state and what the president
and the prime minister of Singapore are
in effect warranted to do is very
different than the kind of urban issues
that are faced by mayor's at the same
time all the problems they face our
problems of Mayors so they have they
have a certain amount of confusion on
those issues they're crushed they for
example they deal to the Malaysia to the
north and Indonesia to the South and
they deal with them as states sure but
on the other hand they are a city not a
state and therefore their dealings with
them are peculiar and not normal what by
the way they have done that's very
important for us though because one of
the other questions which should I hope
come up here's the question of the
inequality injustice which in cities
what about any quality and just well the
answer is cities are no better than
States you know at this they're doing it
very badly but there are cities that
have figured it out and one city that
has is Singapore because what Singapore
has done in its public housing program
which is a little like what Hong Kong
and a few other cities have done is not
subsidized rentals but subsidize the
purchase of housing from private market
developers so they have a public private
scheme that allows people to be
subsidized to buy their apartments and
then
keep what they make from them resell
them move move around at will but in
doing that good thing because you've
created a stakeholder society you've
created a very large middle class
everybody is not a renter everybody is
an owner 85% of people owned on their
apartments and that gives them a stake
holding in the society and makes them
feel good about it in ways and at the
same time the private market likes it
because they provide they build the
housing they provide the housing and the
government is in effect subsidizing the
purchase of housing so is that a better
mechanism than the one we use for
basically making giving you a tax break
on your mortgage payments which was done
for the same reason some while ago and
then turned out to have problems well
yes I mean with the problem the problems
come from them from a mortgage and
banking crisis that we have to separate
from it I mean I think I think the tax
break was a good idea I mean it helped
create the American middle class there's
there's no doubt about it the problem
was it was not very useful in cities it
was very useful in subway it was born of
the suburbs and it allowed houses but in
cities where you didn't buy apartments
the co-op movement was the middle class
and upper class movement you left the
poor out so the subsidy you subsidized
the poor by buying by building project
housing of a kind that we know was
destructive to their lives their morale
and to the neighborhood and what the
Singaporeans have done is subsidized the
purchase of those some of that was done
by the way in the Bronx when they
rebuild low-rise housing to replace the
burned-out buildings there and people
were helped in buying apartments but the
point about Singapore is they've done it
systematically across the board it mean
it's 80 to 85 percent of the population
live in homes apartments it's all
apartments actually they don't really
have houses it's all it goes like this
because there's no room but they own it
and they own it by the way what it means
is that when you first marry you have a
two room apartment you have kids you can
trade it in
buy yourself a four or five row
apartment you get old you stay in the
same building but go back to a one-room
studio but you're in the same building
with your friends and your family you
can trade it in you have the money to
buy it nobody has to do it it becomes
also
retirement pension system because the
value of your home has accrued in ways
that allow you to basically lick the
problems of gender gendered poverty of
the old end of the working class so that
the housing solution seems to be among
the many things the Singaporeans have
done one of the most creative and
interesting as I say it's also been
approved by the private sector because
the private sector provides and builds
the housing that is then subsidized so
that they the money goes around New York
question do you talk to Mayor Bloomberg
know you he doesn't talk to people like
me interesting he will I think Accord
him approvingly when he reads the nice
day like say about it right you might
you do talk to Occupy Wall Street as I
recall and what was was that an urban
event and what was that about from the
standpoint of the perspective of this
book well that and that's that's a great
question Stewart and it is true
imagine a revolution in a cornfield
I mean revolutions take place on public
squares and public thoroughfares they
take place where populations come
together they come they take place in
concentration radicalism a Galit
arianism the civil rights movement all
happens in in towns and they succeeded
by the way in towns in rural counties
civil rights workers were picked off one
by one and murdered but in the towns
together in solidarity they achieved
their successes by Wall Street a good
thing for in New York and it was a
terrific thing for New York was the
three thing for London and it is a city
phenomenon and I think it's a good thing
for all cities and unfortunately in
cities like Oakland where they didn't
figure that out you know they made that
they they both made a mess of it they
actually gave publicity to what they
would think are probably the worst
elements of Occupy the Occupy movement
the more radical and anarchic elements
but in fact it's a communitarian
movement it's been a very healthy
movement and it's typical that cities
are able to I mean that is the essence
of the city that in the in the city and
the boulevards you can you can
demonstrate you can assemble you
the right to assemble was the the right
to the two free assembly was never
necessary in a rural society because
there was nowhere to assemble it wasn't
so you had town censors and growing
cities the assembly was an issue so
thinking of Oakland thinking of the
former mayor of Oakland who's now the
governor of the state
you've probably since you're admiring
mayor has been paying attention to ones
who go on to serve in other offices
often larger officers what songs do you
think and Browns a great case I happen
to work for him the first time around
and acquainted with him this time around
yes he's that much older in the world
was that much older but there's a pre
mayor of Oakland Governor Brown and a
post mayor of Oakland Governor Brown and
there must be other examples like that
these characters learn things as
governors that they carry on to other
positions well here's the most
interesting thing about mayors and this
is simply and you're gonna probably say
oh is that really so very few mayors
among the thousands and thousands of
mayors and go on to other office the
mayor rlt is a terminal office for a lot
of people for very good reasons no New
York City mayor has ever been President
of the United States I mean it just
doesn't have you don't go in fact you'd
very few have gone on to any high we
know Giuliani tried and there's a reason
that mayor's I mean the chapter I'm
working on right now is all about mayors
mayor's are remarkably non-ideological
most of them are independents even if
they don't call themselves that you know
Bloomberg we know is that and UK
ideology has very little to do with
running running a city so very few
mayor's go on and when they do they
haven't been very very successful mayor
lush golf and Moscow was there for 30
years from Brezhnev to Putin he helped
found the unite the the party that Putin
founded but immediately backed out and
said you know these national legislators
don't do anything they don't know how to
govern then worth their doing he's a
critic of the doom and he's a critic of
Putin and Putin finally got him out of
office after 30 years but an awful lot
of people are talking about Boris
Johnson now taking over for David
Cameron Boris Johnson keeps saying you
know
kind of character is since I'm not going
anywhere I love you know governing
London I love being the mayor of London
that's where I want to end my days and
that has been Ed Koch I mean the story
of mayors has not been the story of
stepping stones there are countries like
France and England where mayors are
assignments that people in a party
hierarchy get on their way up the ladder
but Francois Hollande who has just
elected the president of France spent
his first seven years as a mayor of a
small town in southern France that he
wasn't from but he fell in love with the
town he spent seven years there and when
he took the oath of office for the
presidency he went back to that town and
took the oath there so my phrase is
mayors our own voice they come from
their local towns and they like to stay
there and they rarely go on to other
office they are you know some some bacon
looper in Denver was a terrific mayor of
Denver and he's going on to be the
governor but often when they governed
their non-ideological Hickenlooper has
been a very pragmatic non-ideological
governor as well so what they bring with
them when they go on is a very non
ideological and pragmatic temperament
which is often ill suited to the
politics of higher office when ideology
and party politics becomes much more
important but they would be suited to
the kind of global Parliament of the
cities that you would like to see happen
presumably they would what they would be
suited for working in a global problem
would sit there they would go and talk
you know how do you pick up your garbage
do you have dedicated bus lanes you know
that are like Subway's above the ground
what are you doing about bike-share how
I mean the conversations are very when
mayor's talk together I've been there
that it is a very practical kind of
conversation when presidents and prime
ministers talk they talk about warm
peace they talk about trade treaties
they talk about ideology and they talk
about national interests it's it's a
very different political conversation
and one for which mayor's it's not so
much that they're not seated but they
don't have much taste for there's kind
of a practical question from Dove yoga
numa fiscal distress rolls downhill the
federal government pushes the pain down
to the states the state's push it down
the municipalities and serious economic
crises
considers hope to make globalization
progress despite greatly increased
economic hindrances coming from the
state that's a great question it's
exactly right and it's another instance
of interdependence I mean the economic
interdependence means that cities cannot
escape the pain of national and global
economic crisis which is why they demand
and need a say in dealing with those
things but there's no question that many
cities are suffering as a result of
national and global banking crises for
which they're not responsible and over
which they have little authority and
can't do very much about but the other
side of that is what's kind of
remarkable is how many cities have
managed nonetheless to do well and there
I think the proximity of citizens to
public officials the engagement of
citizens in their neighborhoods and in
the cities makes for a somewhat
different relationship there's an
interesting statistic the confidence
level of the American public in Congress
is 19 percent right now the lowest it's
been in a very very long time
in the presidency as an office not in
the particular president it's about
forty four percent Americans have 65
percent plus confidence in their mayor's
in other words of all politicians
they're mayors they see as an extension
of them and that kind of confidence
makes it easier to endure the kind of
critical economic crises cities are
forced to undergo as a consequence of
the banking crisis and also allows the
sense of solidarity between mayors and
their cities that you don't often find
between governors and their state
constituents or presidents and their
national people question from Josh
Weisberg this relates to a presentation
we had several years ago by Paul Romer
who was just then introducing this idea
of charter cities is that something
you've been tracking on no haven't I
mean I'm gonna I've got a research
person on it but I haven't been looking
at it yet does he have a suggestion for
us about what love you know I won't go
through his story but you know I should
just just call Paul he's really good
I'll talk to him
I would do it directly actually it's
because I will you would find a lot
Carter yes what happens when the
metabolisms of cities out pieces the
hinterlands ability to feed it resources
that going to happen and has it happened
is it happening now how does one deal
again it's a very important question and
it speaks to interdependence we know
that the local agriculture movements is
one effort by cities and the regions
around them to find forms of
interdependence that serve both of them
there are those who say it's inefficient
that it's more costly in the long term
economically and that it's a kind of
middle-class phenomenon many cities find
that they had fresh vegetable markets in
the middle-class zones but not in the
gate I was not in the inner city and so
on although those are remediable futures
that that is changing but the
relationship between the city and the
countryside is sustainable the problem
is its proper it's probably most easily
sustainable by agribusiness I mean
agribusiness is there for 2% of the
population to create food for the other
98% of the population and still export
twenty to thirty percent of the American
bounty so there's not a problem of
productivity the problem is in the
economic forms that do that productivity
and whether those mass forms are
compatible with democracy in the life of
the city but I don't the question of
feeding the city I would say is not a
problem the problem of distributing food
so that all cities are fed equally and
all people within the city have access
to those foods is the fundamental
question of injustice and inequality
which has not been solved so there's a
political demographic question
cities seem like they're more liberal
politically than the countryside and you
look at blue states and red states and
blue counties and red counties and all
the rest of and then kind of across the
world
okay that's already interesting I'd love
to hear why you think that's the case if
it is the case that we were moving from
the city people of the world being in
city dwellers being a minority to now
majority to assume being a super
majority I've sent me in a
liberalisation of global politics is
basically going on here
you have just depicted the Tea Party's
nightmare
because they know you're fond dream they
and well yeah but they read they read
demographics and they read urbanization
and they would agree with they would say
exactly right Stuart
we are urbanizing we are cosmopolitan
izing we are multicultural izing our
populations in ways that are going to
create an evermore somewhat progressive
population that's not to say that I the
the Catholic in Latino immigrants don't
in many ways have cultural norms that
are quite conservative and so on so it's
not you know it's not it's not black and
white but there's no question that it
organization and cosmopolitan sation
those very words say it do you talk
about the urbane and the cosmopolitan
and the progressive and the open and the
multicultural cities are based on
openness to multicultural no big-city
mayor has the problem with immigration
that small rural counters do anymore
than any big business have this problem
with immigration that's why in fact the
immigration illegal happens because
there are so many jobs that nobody else
will do and the business wants to hire
people to do so the trends do without
question trends liberally in a certain
limited kind of sense and that will
continue and right now the only
difference is the demographics don't
vote their numbers so that the new
demographics the single mothers with
children working mothers with children
immigrants Latinos young people
generally vote far less than
old white suburban rural folks vote so
right now we are still out voted in this
country by the old demographic even
though the new demographic has more or
less in terms of the majority of the
nation
it's where the country is going so and
we it's also built into our political
system the Senate allows 20 states
roughly and the population of 20 states
to dominate the American Congress so you
have 10 percent or 20 percent of the
population
systematically blocking what 80% of the
population wants to do and that's gonna
become a more serious problem the
Constitution was written in times when
we were a rural republic and most cities
had a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand people Jefferson distrusted
cities and thought country yeomen were
the salt of the earth
he didn't to some extent that is true
you know we talk about urban corruption
and I have a long chapter on the dispute
between country and city the moral
dispute between country in the city and
the way in which just listen to country
music if you want to hear in America a
Liturgy of what's wrong with cities and
then city folks you know and and that's
it's very strong it's very powerful and
there's a certain you know truth to it
we talked about the de ration nation of
cities and the uprooting of people in
the loneliness of cities and so on you
listen to urban music to or listen to
urban blues and you hear the other side
of that so there's a very real there's a
really value disconnect between country
life rooted in the land and city life
rooted in urban de rasa nation which is
also freedom and Jay McInerney you know
Yuri Jame a cannery and there's a story
of total freedom licensed despair
hopelessness murder you know you name it
all of which go hand in hand but then
can trash that with the book a couple
years ago 20 years ago by Michael Lacey
called Wisconsin Death Trip right now
great he went back and looked at the
police blotters four small villages in
Wisconsin in the 19th century people ate
kitchen matches to commit suicide it was
like Governor Walker was everywhere back
in those days and he
and it was it was it was a it was a
terrible story you know and then there's
the idiocy Marx talks about the idiocy
of rural life and you know the
impossibility and the barbarism of rural
so and the people in the country talk
about you know the incivility and the
rassa nation of people in the city so
that is a debate that goes on but the
fact is demographically the debate is
going to be won decisively by
cosmopolitanism and the city and that's
a good thing if you value difference if
you value multiculturalism if you value
tolerance if you bought value a variety
a few value art and so on and the things
that people there's a pace question here
to then things happen to hot new york
minute in new york and in the city we're
multitasking every which way doing
everything but voting it sounds like and
doing faster and faster and the whole
deal of real life is that it operates at
a seasonal pace and the long now from
our standpoint it would seem like
resides in the countryside and the short
now which is where brian eno first got
the notion of that there ought to be
along now because he saw the short now
being pathological in manhattan is isn't
cities just going to drive our our
pathetically short attention span into
micro nano form so that we can't
actually pay attention to anything for
very long it sure is and you're the guy
was a long now foundation i mean that
which we started in the city I know
that's why then you got in the wrong
that's my point you need you have to go
out to you know the valley I guess with
it to take it somewhere else because I
mean that is - I mean this short this
short term of city life the fastest in
the pace of the city speed is what the
city is all about there's no question
about urban life is much faster than
comin we used to think that was bad is
it actually good
well it's good but like everything I'm a
dialectician it's good and it's bad you
know so I mean the short now is okay a
lot of things in the short now you know
I mean sex on the lawn now you know
there's I know that's a short now as far
as I can see and a good thing too not
that short focus and for my follow-up
question let's move on to the next
question Kevin Hart does a question how
should essence cooperate with Frankfort
to preserve the benefits of the euro
well the problem is Frankfort and Athens
are not working together the European
Bank in Frankfurt is the face of Europe
in Athens okay if the citizens of
Frankfurt were involved I suspect you
would get a agreement that would not
focus on radical austerity and the
dismantling of the Greek welfare state
you would certainly get a curtailing of
expenses you'd have to have cutbacks
obviously it's you know it's overheated
it can't do it but but the reality is
the interface and Europe means the
European Bank Europe means the
bureaucrats it does not mean Europe
cities and it does not mean democracy
the real problem the crisis in Europe
comes because Europe is a technocratic
economic and fiscal entity it is not a
community or democratic entity and if
cities were allowed to define Europe it
would be a very very different Europe
did they once yeah
mention Hanseatic League and things like
yeah no they did and they in certain we
were talking before yeah and Italy was
defined by the cities for a long time
all they did was kill each other a lot
and has very good art or actually they
didn't kill each other they hire the
Swiss to come in and the Swiss were very
good because the squish in the beginning
when the Swiss first came to Italy they
were they came in as proxy warriors as
mercenaries and because they were all
from the same families they wouldn't
kill each other even though there are
different sides peace out there and it
was chests no they said you know you win
this one you know you're well deployed
you know you can have this one
they but I'm serious actually they
really didn't kill each other and the
new Charles in France in the 15th
century when national armies were raised
from peasants and so on that's when they
started killing so the very people died
in the wars of the 13th and 14th
centuries the best argument for
mercenaries I've ever heard
it is it's in fact there's a whole
solution path I can see that but they
have to be Swiss murder they have new
mercenaries from the same play you have
to hire them from one source so they're
all related to one is this how the Swiss
wound up guarding the Pope fur it is
exactly how they bid that's that's the
you know residue of 15th century
mercenaries history is full of good
ideas Rick says you spoke powerfully
about the informal bottom-up connection
the cities are making with each other in
the face of formal top-down nation-state
governance so I make the city relations
formal yeah good and great and and by
the way I'm ending look I wrote a number
of years ago it's called strong
democracy it was about bottom-up
participation and one of the things that
I'm finding is that the way cities
operate is much more a model of strong
democracy when I say formal you know I
don't mean make them top-down I just
mean formalize that is to say it's great
that the councillor from Chicago
happened to be in Seville Spain and saw
some bike share ideas that he could use
in Chicago but would it be great if a
thousand mayor's came together and could
share ideas systematically about bike
share so you don't the wait for someone
to take a trip to Seville to get this
great idea there are a lot of very
interesting urban ideas around another
for about 10% the cost of a subway you
can have a dedicated separated bus lane
no other traffic's there it stops the
local and so on with its own curbside
and so on it's a brilliant suggest it's
been now used in a number of cities in
Africa and Latin America I hope it's
going to be used here but again that's
an idea that if you formalize the
relationships of transportation
secretaries from cities so they come
together regularly that exchange time
using formalized in that sense not
create a top-down regularize rather than
normalize regular life systematize maybe
to do it so that you you in effect I
mean my notion of a parliament of cities
is is a place where there's an awful lot
of exchange of ideas going on and a lot
of it can be web-based by the way you
know
you know a lot of that can happen and a
lot of it is happening with and type in
bike share you know on Google and you'll
find you know an extraordinary amount of
information about what's going on and
they're about 300 bike share programs
including you know we have Code for
America people here who are charging
ahead and this sort of thing I trust you
have what they're doing and yet I've
been following them or not just a great
work thank you for agreeing in thank you
for coming this was great man thank you
very much thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]